hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's highly
requested edition of what I eat in a day
youtuber reviews I'm going to be taking
a look at drumroll please
Sadia from pick-up lines you guys have
requested this review pretty much every
single week so finally we're gonna do it
if for no other reason than to really
demonstrate an amazing vegan youtuber
that you should definitely be following
now for those of you who are unfamiliar
with Sadia she's a Canadian vegan
dietitian who lives in the Netherlands
and runs the very popular YouTube
channel pick up lines and with an
impressive like three million YouTube
subscribers I am pretty proud of this
fellow Rd now Before we jump into my
review I want to start with my general
disclaimer that the information in this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only and you should
always seek out the help of a registered
dietitian or medical professional for
your unique needs and on that note let's
meet Satya starting with her date 1
meals
[Music]
question for you do you add your milk to
your granola or your granola to your
milk okay so I just have to say that saw
Dias channel is just so so dreamy and so
is her actual food so before this clip
we saw Satya prepare a big batch of
granola featuring oats quinoa almonds
coconut seeds sugar dried fruit and nut
butter I also loved the idea of making
granola from scratch and saw Diaz
doesn't seem restrictive or a deity at
all while still being super nourishing
she's balancing real sugar and real oil
with super nutrient-dense ingredients
like nuts seeds oats quinoa and dried
fruit and we've got a really nice
balance here of carbs from the fruit and
grains
plus fat and protein from all of those
nuts and seeds there's actually about 14
grams of protein here so definitely not
bad but if you were having this let's
say after a workout and you needed a
little bit more a really easy swap would
be to go for soy yogurt over coconut
yogurt which is what Saudi I was serving
hers with because soy yogurt has about
10 grams of protein per cup versus about
one or two in the coconut let's see what
lunch has in store and I would always
recommend having some kind of greens
with this arugula works really really
well but we've just got some sprouts
that we need to use up so we're gonna
okay I need to know who has a trio of
beautiful sprouts just like hanging out
in their kitchen other than this woman I
mean these meals are just like too
pretty to be real no but seriously I
love this fresh take on like a green
pesto using sun-dried tomatoes instead
you know pesto is one of those super
versatile staples and I love that Satya
uses almonds instead of expensive pine
nuts which also adds higher amounts of
protein fiber calcium and
monounsaturated fats compared to pine
nuts so not only are you saving some
money but you're also getting an extra
nutrition boost as well
now I also love the addition of
nutritional yeast to boost up the
protein and the vitamin b12 while adding
that care
eristic kind of parmesan flavor let's
move on to dinner
load it off with some tzatziki yeah I
like to drizzle on a little bit of hot
sauce and then that's it dessert YUM
this is great I mean falafels are just
this excellent vegan plant-based protein
option and if you can make it from
scratch it makes an awesome batch prep
meal that you can easily pop in the
freezer and just like pull out in a
pinch I also find falafel is one of
those foods that is really approachable
to both vegans and non-vegans alike I
mean we've got a nice amount of protein
and fiber from the chickpeas and peas
we've got carbs from the pita healthy
fats from the tahini and flax and of
course tons of crunchy colorful veg this
does not feel like restrictive diet food
it's really just delicious balanced and
ultimately a wholesome meal and it's so
refreshing to see in the vegan YouTube
space let's take a look at dessert pop
on the lid and then put it in the fridge
for at least one hour
that looks super YUM and I love that
this mousse uses only three ingredients
aquafaba tea and dark chocolate so if
you are not in the know of this little
hack aqua fava is the liquid found in
any can of cooked pulses like beans peas
and lentils basically the small bits of
protein sugar and starches leach out of
the cooked pulses resulting in a viscous
liquid that makes a really magical
foaming agent and baking substitute for
egg whites there is currently not a ton
of information about its nutritional
benefits as aqua fava as a cooking agent
wasn't even discovered until 2014
however what we do know is that it's
relatively low in protein calories and
overall nutrition so with that said if
you're not specifically following a
vegan diet
it may be nutritionally beneficial to
stick with using regular eggs and your
baking as they're just more
nutritionally dense but if you're at it
eggs and you need something in a pinch
aqua fava can definitely save the day
it's also a really great way to reduce
waste if you're opening a can of beans
to make falafel for example anyways so I
love any hack that will just cut back on
the amount of waste that we have in our
day let's move on to day 2 and have a
look what Satya is eating while on
holiday in Spain
ah this breakfast looks so good I mean
we've got some healthy fats from the
Chia and the peanut butter
we've got fiber and carbs from the
millet and the fruit and we also have
almost 20 grams of protein from the
mixture of the soy milk yogurt mix and
the millet so that is pretty good I also
love how Sadia inserts like really
helpful nutrition nuggets in with her
recipes like for example mentioning that
millet is actually gluten free so it's
great for anyone who has celiac disease
or gluten intolerance she also
highlights that she's using calcium
fortified soy milk which may be
important for anyone following a vegan
diet as statistically people who are
following plant-based diets may have
lower calcium intakes she also provides
some really practical cooking tips for
cooking millet by recommending soaking
it overnight prior to cooking to help
get rid of the nutrient inhibitors that
can interfere with nutrient absorption
so Sadia is specifically referring to
phytates or phytic acid which is really
a compound found in varying amounts in a
variety of plant-based foods like seeds
grains legumes and nuts like sodium
mentioned earlier in this clip phytic
acid can interfere with the absorption
of nutrients like potassium calcium iron
zinc and magnesium but that's not a
reason to avoid plant-based foods like
certain YouTube carnivores might say the
good news is that food processing
techniques like soaking sprouting and
germination can actually enhance
nutritional quality digestibility and
bioavailability of the nutrients
contained in things like millet seeds
I'm also glad to see that Satya is
highlighting this kind of lesser-known
ingredient to her followers because
millet actually provides a good amount
of protein calcium and iron ok let's see
what Satya is having for a snack as she
goes on like a little bit of a walk with
her partner through some sand dunes yeah
I usually put it in the drink because
it's just extra fiber especially when
you're traveling and you know you're not
really regular
so then when you put the little cheese
seats in it and then you're just
drinking your fiber essentially and to
me it's kind of like bubble tea no and
especially when you flavor the water -
Oh
pistachios we've got these oranges which
are I think the most okay so I love
flavoring water with vegetables and
fruit and herbs especially if somebody's
you feel like you're getting a little
tired or bored of plain h2o and the chia
seed bubble tea hack genius
I never thought to do something like
that so I loved when I learned something
new from a fellow youtuber because let's
be real for a hot minute folks Travel
constipation is a very real thing and it
sucks when you're trying to enjoy your
holiday and you feel like crap because
you literally can't crap but it's also
really common often because the stress
of traveling changes in sleep eating and
exercise routine and often drinking more
alcohol or eating less vegetables or
fiber even as dietitians are not immune
to these effects so adding some chia
seeds to your water is really a great
way to kind of kill two birds with one
stone by staying hydrated while also
getting in that extra fiber boost at the
same time one tablespoon of chia seeds
provides five grams of fiber
which is about 20% of your daily needs
and chia seed is a soluble fiber which
forms a gel-like consistency which
really helps add bulk and moisture to
stool which just makes it easier to pass
so this is definitely an awesome and
easy practical travel tip as for her
snack I mean definitely some really
excellent snack choices right here we've
got a really good combination of what I
call the hunger crushing combo that I
always talk about when it comes to
snacks we've got some healthy fats we've
got protein we got fiber from the
pistachios an energy bar we've got some
beautiful oranges in there for hydration
and energizing carbs and while I could
not find specific nutrition info on
these particular
Barr's I looked everywhere I do know
that they're made out of date nuts and
cocoa powder so again we've got a nice
combination of fat carbs and a little
bit of protein getting in some carbs
with fat or protein is a good option for
a casual hike in the dunes like this
because unlike when we're doing a sprint
for our workout we're fat fiber or
protein may kind of slow you down for
longer duration slower steady exercise
like this you'll want some energy from
carbs but you'll also want that energy
to last and having that fat or protein
mixed in there can definitely help with
that let's see what Satya has packed for
lunch can I go on a picnic with Satya
honestly this I love this lunch even
more than day one and we're on holiday
so that's crazy but we've got some
plant-based protein from the lentils
healthy fats from the avocado and olives
cars from that beautiful bread and of
course a lot of beautiful colorful
vegetables I mean and doesn't everything
taste better on a picnic blanket with
your partner just so cute anyway I just
love how Saudi adjust subtly puts on her
dietician hat by being mindful about
incorporating plant-based protein with
her meal by adding some lentils in there
while also highlighting the protein and
the fiber that they provide Sadia does
talk in this clip later on briefly about
the gas promoting compounds and lentils
which are actually carbohydrates in the
fog knob family called oligosaccharides
now while illegal saccharides can make
some people gas here than others they
are actually highly beneficial for our
gut and the gassy impact
often comes down to how they're prepared
so life satyam mentions in this clip
draining and rinsing Candle legumes is
one way to lower the oligosaccharide
levels and if you're cooking dried
lentils
you should also soak and rinse them
prior to cooking however I will say that
canned rinsed legumes have a lower level
of legal saccharides than dried legumes
so if your particular
be sensitive to beans and FODMAPs can't
maybe a better option for you in
addition if you're not used to eating a
lot of legumes it's important to
introduce them slowly over several weeks
to allow your digestive system to really
kind of adjust while also ensuring that
you're drinking enough water taken
together all of those things should help
minimize the effects let's move on to
dinner a lentil burger and in it I have
to look because I don't know exactly is
mustard coconut milk lettuce tomatoes
some zucchini of vegan dill mayonnaise
and some potatoes
this looks super good and to drink I
just got a decaf soy milk latte usually
I'm fine with caffeine at night but just
to be safe that does look so good and
the great thing about the global rise in
the plant-based eating movement is that
there's now a greater variety of
plant-based meal options abroad so
there's really no need to just tuck into
a boring plate of shredded lettuce while
your friends are enjoying their regular
burgers and fries but this looks really
really delicious I mean we've got a
lentil burger packed with plant-based
protein and fiber and a side of crispy
potatoes now I know a lot of you are
going to say well Abbey where are the
vegetables I mean a burger and potatoes
isn't exactly healthy is it of course
when we talk about a balanced plate that
has generally filled a quarter with
protein a quarter with starch and half
vegetables we would probably want to add
like a side salad with this and
obviously Sadia knows this but the same
way I talked about the restaurant meals
on Myles channel from healthy crazy-cool
when we look at the context of this day
with all of these beautiful veggies and
fruit that we saw a breakfast and lunch
there's no need to totally obsessed I
mean we're on vacation for goodness sake
I was lucky if I saw a few servings of
vegetables a day when I was traveling in
Italy so I really actually appreciate
Saudi as flexibility to just eat out it
seems like Satya is simply choosing
meals that sound delicious to her in
that moment while still considering what
will ultimately satisfy her and
compliment her plant-based lifestyle
super intuitive and honestly like a
pleasure to watch another thing I want
to flag is that my critique of each
individual youtubers diet is going to
look different because I'm looking at
their day and the messages that they
communicate as a whole Sadia isn't going
from zero to a hundred with clean kale
smoothies to cheat days she's also not
eating six portions of salad at lunch
and nothing else so of course when you
eat a good amount of produce at one meal
it's okay to have much less or nothing
at all later on in the day okay now
since we couldn't find another what I
eat in a day video that wasn't like a
travel day I wanted to round this review
off by looking at some of Saudi as
popular recipes on our Channel starting
with a breakfast recipe and when you're
ready to enjoy your wrap just add the
tofu scramble and the sweet potato mix
to the wrap along with the slight bell
peppers and some avocado and if you like
it spicy some sriracha hot sauce
okay I just have to say that I think
tofu scrambles are an awesome vegan
alternative to scrambled eggs they're
super easy just as satisfying and
nutrient packed the crumbled tofu gives
a similar texture to scrambled eggs and
the nutritional yeast adds some of that
cheesy flavor plus some protein and a
tumeric also adds some color but in this
meal we're getting a nice combination of
some complex carbs from the sweet potato
and tortilla healthy fats from the
avocado as well as colorful vegetables
in the form of bell peppers personally I
would probably double the bell peppers
in there or throw in some spinach or
greens like saadia actually recommends
as an option just to get some more non
starchy vegetal this is a super
flavorful and nutrient packed breakfast
option that I think everyone can enjoy
regardless of their dietary preferences
this is also a really great high protein
breakfast option as one cup of tofu
provides a whopping 20 grams of protein
plus the nutritional yeast adds even
more I actually have a similar tofu
scramble breakfast burrito recipe on the
blog which I love to have as a
post-workout meal for this very reason
not only does tofu add a ton of protein
and texture to vegan meals but it also
provides a great source of calcium
providing 90 percent of your daily needs
per cup now I want to just mention that
not all tofu products are created equal
so make sure that you check the label
and look for one that is a calcium set
or has calcium sulfite on the label to
get these bone boosting benefits okay
let's move on to lunch the Vega apps are
pretty huge once they've been filled out
so we considered a whole baguette to be
2 servings so feel free to have as much
or as little as you'd like oh now I like
need a bond me sandwich because not only
are bond me sandwiches one of the most
delicious sandwiches in the Sandwich
Kingdom but as Satya proves they can
also be made on a budget which is
something we all like to hear so this
vegan Bonnie has some protein packed
marinated tofu and fresh veggies and
pickled veggies and assert on a
beautiful whole-wheat baguette I also
love that Satya does
a quick pickling of the carrots
otherwise known as a quickl which is a
great way to really add some lovely
vinegary tartness to your veggies
without having to wait for pickles to
actually ferment now some of you may be
wondering if quick pickling has the same
probiotic benefits as pickled fermented
foods like kimchi or sauerkraut
unfortunately the answer is no while
pickling and fermentation are two
methods of preservation that adds some
kind of sour tangy flavor to veggies
they do have different preparation
methods which ultimately yield different
nutritional results so to compare
pickling involves adding an acid like
vinegar to vegetables to achieve that
sour flavor
now even though vinegar is a product of
fermentation pickled foods are not
fermented by default and unfortunately
they don't produce the same probiotic
benefits as fermented foods fermented
foods on the other hand get their sour
flavor due to the reaction between the
sugars in the food and bacteria no acid
is actually added so when it comes to
quick pickling it's more about the
flavor it provides rather than the
probiotic benefits but if you did want
to boost the probiotics in this meal you
could totally add some kimchi and that
would absolutely be a match made in
heaven and if you want to bump up the
veg content even more you could totally
serve some of those quick pickle carrots
and those beautiful cucumber ribbons on
the side as well that to me it would be
the ultimate complete meal I also have
to say that I love how Sadia uses
non-judgmental language in this clip by
mentioning that she would probably
consider a whole baguette to be two
servings but you could eat as much or as
little as you'd like
so rather than relying on external cues
like serving sizes that a dietician or
somebody on the internet has decided for
you Sadia is suggesting that you rely on
your own internal cues to determine how
much or how little feels right for you
and finally let's finish off with one of
her classic dinner recipes
so I am so into veganizing traditional
meat based dishes like butter chicken so
this is totally up my alley I mean to me
anyways the best part of any curry is
not the meat in it it's the sauce
because let's be real whenever I have
curry leftovers
I literally just sometimes used the
leftover sauce as like a dip for bread
because that is my favorite part
but anyways Sadia uses cashews in her
curry to add that kind of creaminess
factor without any cream and she also
gives an awesome tip to add a little
squeeze of lemon juice to the curry at
the end because it brings out the
aromatic flavors and also because the
vitamin C can help your body better
absorb the iron from the cashews in the
tofu this is a great tip as research has
shown that individuals following a vegan
or vegetarian diet are more likely to
have low iron stores compared to non
vegetarians well it is totally possible
to get enough iron on a vegan diet
pairing non heme iron rich food sources
with a source of vitamin C is a great
way to maximize iron absorption other
great sources of plant-based iron in
addition to tofu include legumes tempeh
soy beans nuts seeds whole grains and
leafy greens these sources could easily
be paired with vitamin C rich veggies
like bell peppers tomatoes broccoli
Brussels sprouts and dark leafy greens
so for example this might look like
having a lentil salad with some bell
peppers and lime juice like Saudi is
picnic lunch on day two or adding some
broccoli or Brussels sprouts to a tofu
stir-fry or making a grain salad with
some quinoa spinach pumpkin seeds and a
spritz of lime juice or maybe even just
pairing a handful of almonds with some
fruit as a balanced snack it does not
need to be complicated as honestly these
pairings are quite intuitive and natural
and ultimately really delicious I also
love that we have our protein in the
tofu we've got fats from the cashews and
carbs from the rice and not
all that is missing is a little bit more
veg so if we paired this with a simple
cucumber salad or some roasted spicy
cheese like broccoli or cauliflower for
example we would be all set but of
course this is just a recipe idea and
not an actual meal so on to our big
questions in general is this way of
eating balanced absolutely I would
expect nothing less from a fellow
dietitian and part of the reason I put
off doing this review was because I
watch Satya for plant-based inspiration
all the time myself and I knew this
would be like almost too easy to go
through but I'm glad that I'm doing this
for no other reason than to give credit
where credit is due and ultimately to
introduce you to Satya if you're not
already one of her 2.8 1 million
subscribers but seriously folks not only
are her meals super balanced easy and
delicious but watching her cook in that
gorgeous rustic kitchen is honestly
therapeutic as for Saudi as nutrition
from her what eat in a day videos Sadia
is unsurprisingly
hitting all of her macronutrient ranges
and her calories for the day she's
getting about 18 milligrams of iron from
this day which is the exact daily iron
recommendation for a menstruating women
and about 38 grams of fiber which while
above the 25 gram target that most
people don't reach is not the extreme 70
to 90 gram range that we've seen from a
lot of other plant-based youtubers while
she didn't mention it specifically in
this video which I would have liked to
see she does discuss her supplement
regime elsewhere and the importance of
taking a vitamin b12 and vitamin d3 as
well as an algae based omega-3
supplement so she could maybe add a
little calcium supplement into the mix
because she was about 15% below the
recommended intake but it's also really
hard to judge what she is and isn't
regularly getting since all of this is
just from one home and one travel based
what a in a day video now I know a lot
of people often assume that veganism is
unsustainable or may put one at risk for
nutritional deficiencies and while this
may be true for some cases
we've seen so often on my channel
following a plant-based vegan diet can
certainly be done in a safe nourishing
and sustainable way and I think Satya is
a really excellent example of that her
meals are beautifully balanced with a
wide variety of carbs healthy fats and
plant-based proteins I mean we're not
just seeing green juice and banana only
smoothies for every single meal and
while she definitely considers how to
add more nutritional value to her meal I
mean she has a dietician after all she
also considers things like texture
flavor satisfaction and how to make her
meals more digestible and easier to
prepare what I appreciate most is that
Satya seems to be all about adding
nutritious foods to your diet not taking
things away which is the philosophy that
I also try to promote here at Abby's
kitchen and this philosophy is evident
in many of her nutrition videos where
she does a really great job at
communicating the evidence in a simple
and understandable way with the
underlying message being that all foods
can fit in moderation so for instance in
her video on oils and fats
she doesn't demonize one type of fat
over the other but rather provides a
balanced overview of all the different
types of fat in the diet their benefits
their disadvantages whole food sources
of those fats and the types of fats that
we should consume more often like
unsaturated fats and the ones that we
should consume less often like saturated
fats and trans fats
similarly in her video about sugar she
provides an evidence-based overview of
the purpose of consuming sugar in the
diet the different types of sugar like
complex carbs versus simple carbs as
well as the positive and negative
effects of sugar on the body she
certainly doesn't discourage sugar or
carbohydrate consumption but rather
provides helpful tips on how to manage
overall intake and to slow sugar
absorption down by pairing carbohydrates
with a source of protein or fat which
might sound familiar to you guys because
that's basically my recommendation
pretty much all day
every day now are there any problematic
claims or assumptions made by this
channel honestly you guys know that I
have reviewed a lot of vegan content on
the channel and unfortunately they
haven't all been winners but saadia is a
breath of fresh air not only is it great
to have another evidence-based dietitian
here on YouTube but a responsible vegan
one at that and the fact that millions
of viewers enjoy her content gives me
confidence that anyone who's considering
eating more plant-based will do so in an
informed safe and enjoyable way if
they're watching saw Dias content and
also a really delicious way because
let's be honest you certainly don't have
to be vegan to enjoy the amazing recipes
here on saw DEA's Channel
of course someone out there is gonna
slam me for not being hard enough on her
so what I would say is that I do find
her what I need a video to almost seemed
a little idealistic for most people I
mean I get the sense that Satya is
trying to use her what a in a day format
to kind of share specific recipes from
her blog less so to just document a
genuine day in her life but some people
may interpret this as a need to making
granola falafel pesto chocolate mousse
all those things from scratch in one day
I mean sometimes you just got to eat
leftovers and a bowl of cereal and call
it a day most people just don't have
that much time to do that much prep
every single day which may make vegan
eating seem a little unattainable but if
you use saw Dias content as inspiration
and even just decide to make like one of
these meals each week then I think
you're actually gonna get a lot out of
her Channel so while study is really
amazing at what she does and her recipes
provide a ton of wholesome food
inspiration don't feel that you need to
put pressure on yourself to be an
Instagram friendly vegan meal prep
master overnight okay so finally what
can we take away from Saudi as'll ah so
much folks I really appreciate that
Satya doesn't push a vegan agenda on to
her followers but
sted promotes the benefits of including
more plant-based foods into the diet
which is beneficial for everyone vegan
or otherwise I say it all the time
eating more plant-based has been shown
to have a variety of health benefits
including improved blood sugar levels
and lower risk of developing type 2
diabetes and may also be protective
against certain cancers and heart
disease due to an increased intake of
fruits veggies legumes nuts and soy
products so while you don't necessarily
have to be vegan to reap the benefits of
eating more plant-based saw Dias Channel
is an amazing resource for anyone
looking to eat more plant-based foods
without feeling like you're making a
huge sacrifice saw diaz recipes are
generally pretty accessible wholesome
and delicious and she is amazing at
sneaking in little cooking hacks and
nutrition tips that even beginners can
apply in their life when it comes to
transitioning to veganism
Sadia actually has a whole beginner's
guide to veganism that provides simple
sustainable actionable tips for her
followers for instance she talks about
stocking up on essential vegan pantry
staples adding foods like legumes slowly
into the diet to allow your digestive
system to adjust getting regular blood
work done to monitor for improved
biomarkers like cholesterol as well as
possible nutritional deficiencies she
also talks about the importance of
taking vitamin b12 and vitamin D and in
another video she's shown taking a algae
based omega-3 supplement and consuming a
Brazil nut with her supplements for
extra selenium you can also trust that
all of this information is evidence
based and not sensationalized extremism
as we often see on the Internet
Sadia also talks a lot about having a
healthy mindset as you go through this
process giving yourself time to practice
preparing vegan meals honoring your
hunger thinking about foods that you can
add in rather than take away giving
yourself permission to enjoy food and
vegan treats acknowledging that
lifestyle changes like this aren't
linear and it's okay to mess up and so
much more many of us are so used to just
black-and-white messaging
that we need to go from zero to a
hundred in a day that any lifestyle
change has to be perfect and precise and
if we mess up just a little bit that we
failed and the vegan community often
perpetuates this with a lot of really
dogmatic food policing that goes on I've
heard from so many of you that you've
been called out by certain vegan
influencers for not being vegan enough
that is just not how you inspire change
the reality is changing our diet whether
that's going plant base or upping our
fiber or reducing our intake of
saturated fat is a process and we need
to be compassionate and patient with
ourselves to meet ourselves where we are
and speaking of meeting ourselves where
we are Sadia also covers some really
amazing intuitive eating principles on
her channel like rejecting the diet
mentality and how to honor your hunger
she discusses the importance of
developing a nourishing and trusting
relationship with food
one that doesn't dichotomize food as
good and bad and also giving yourself
permission to eat all foods and find
food freedom which are all concepts that
I wholeheartedly believe in and I
discuss at length on my channel here she
also maintains that intuitive eating and
strengthening your relationship with
food is a process that ultimately takes
time unlearning behavior and our
thoughts and beliefs about food and
eating is not something that necessarily
can be done just overnight the same goes
for veganism
and pretty much all things in life it's
those small manageable changes that will
ultimately lead to sustainable long-term
outcomes so that is what I also
personally really advocate for finally
not only the saw Diaz Channel have some
amazing vegan recipe videos and
nutrition content but she also has some
really wonderful health and wellness
content to improve overall mental and
emotional well-being
for instance she's got some videos on
how to decrease stress improve
productivity some guided meditations
creating healthy habits time management
overcoming feelings of failure and
finding balance I mean this girl really
does
at all so whether you're in the mood for
some plant-based recipe inspo or you
need some feel-good compassionate
encouragement to help you meet your
goals there is certainly something for
everyone on the pickup lines Channel and
I honestly could not recommend it enough
bottom line whether you're a seasoned
vegan or simply interested in eating
more plant-based saw Dias channel is the
place to be for some really wholesome
evidence-based and aesthetically
pleasing content you can guarantee that
you'll be getting knowledgeable and
informed nutrition advice from a
registered dietician that encourages
balance sustainability and self
compassion wrapped up in a plant-based
package
I am personally a huge fan and really
not surprised that she's had the success
that she's had well that is all for
today folks if you like this video
please be sure to give it the thumbs up
Linnea comp below with who you'd like to
see me review next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]